from the environments clean energy
finance forum and i'll be your host
today
we're excited to present the third and
final webinar in a series focused on
accessing creative revenue sources for
clean energy in the united states
today's presentation has been brought to
you by the team at the yale center for
business in the environments blueprint
for efficiency
which is in its sixth year providing
public webinars
emphasizing the latest trends and
opportunities for energy efficiency
we're also thrilled to be co-hosting
this series with the council for
development finance agencies the cdfa
it's been a really interesting and
informative series so far and we're
really looking forward to another great
webinar today
so the topic today is advancing energy
finance which policies have the greatest
the biggest impact rather
we'll be looking at a range of policies
currently in place and being considered
around the us
to support investment in renewables and
energy efficiency and discuss the
context in which different policy
options might be the most effective or
easy to implement
so i'd like to start by welcoming our
excellent panel of speakers
first up we have dr devishri sahar
senior policy analyst and associate
fellow at the brookings institute's
metropolitan policy program
following her will be casey bell
senior economist and finance policy lead
at the american council for an energy
efficient economy cac
finally we have jason ridenberg director
of research and advisory services for
the cdfa
each presentation is recorded and
available through the yale center for
business and the environment website
and the blueprint for efficiency itunes
u page
a link to download the slides from
today's presentation has also been
posted in the chat window
i'd like to remind our listeners that
we'll leave plenty of time at the end
for a moderated discussion with all of
our speakers so please type any
questions that you might have into the
go to meeting chat window and with that
i'd like to hand it over to uh devastry
thanks michael and good afternoon uh
everyone i'm jivashri saha an associate
fellow at brookings metropolitan policy
program
and it's a pleasure to welcome so many
of you to this discussion on how to
advance clean energy finance and which
policies have the biggest impact can we
have the next slide please
so this is really an exciting time for
the clean energy sector one that is
characterized by a changing landscape
and new opportunities
uh renewable energy for instance has
become a technology of choice for many
americans accounting for nearly 40
percent of all new domestic power
capacity installed in 2013
and the array of technologies is
increasingly becoming cost competitive
with conventional energy sources and
costs continue to fall
according to bloomberg's new energy
finance private sector investment in the
u.s clean energy sector surpassed
hundred billion dollars in 2012 2013
stimulating economic development and
supporting thousands of jobs
despite this substantial progress clean
energy still suffers from serious
funding and financing gaps
a recent report by the center for
american progress noted that the
transition to a clean energy future in
the united states alone requires 200
billion dollars of investment per year
for the next 20 years so where is this
money going to come from
next slide please
brookings research has previously
documented that federal policy and
subsidy support for clean energy has
declined by about 75
in dollar terms since the height of the
2008 recovery act
meanwhile it's hardly news to any of you
in attendance today that fiscal stress
and political gridlock have not only
greatly reduced the availability of
top-down subsidies and grants from
washington in recent years but promised
to depress their availability for the
foreseeable future
and at the same time state and local
governments are also facing budget
problems that will likely preclude
efforts on their part to offset the
federal pullback with new grant and
subsidy programs so the implication of
all this is that either with or without
federal support different types of
innovative financing mechanisms are
required to scale up the clean energy
industry as it weathers a period of
inconsistent policy support next slide
please
at brookings we have been trying to
understand how states and region can
make progress on their own regardless of
the situation in washington
in this way we have sought in the last
three years to identify and promote some
of the most promising state and local
experiments at financing clean energy
scale up without direct support or
grants from washington
working with blue milford and clean
energy group we noted how a number of
state clean energy funds have been
experimenting with a broader industry
development focus as opposed to simply
funding individual projects
similarly we have worked with cdfa and
blue milford at clean energy group on
scaling up bond financing for clean
energy projects and uh jason will talk
more on that
finally we have worked with reed hunt
and can berlin at the coalition for
green capital on state green banks which
i'm going to discuss in more lengths
today next slide
so one of the more interesting
experiments that is going on in the
country is uh state green banks
green banks are nothing but you know
state chartered financing authorities
that use limited public resources to
leverage greater private investment in
clean energy and their goal is to
grow the clean energy market as quickly
as possible while saving money for
consumers and preserving taxpayer
dollars so how do they work exactly
let's say a homeowner wants to make
energy efficiency upgrades or install
solar panels but might not be able to
pay for the expensive equipment a
private investor or a bank could loan
money to the owner and earn a return but
often that that's not what's what's
happening
um the private investor may be hesitant
to make loans if they're unfamiliar with
the equipment being financed or if they
are unsure that the owner would repay
so enter green banks which can help
lower the risk for private lenders and
investors and one way they do this is
through credit enhancement such as you
know insurance against default a green
bank can agree to cover some of a
private lender's losses if borrowers
don't repay their loans
improving or enhancing the credit
quality of the original loan
and with lower risk loan originators are
often
willing to make more loans possibly at
lower interest rates and thus a history
of loan performance bills so essentially
what green banks are doing is that
they're making sure that the supply and
demand for reasonably priced capital
meet and the market for clean energy
growth
and to be financially self-sustaining
green banks offer finance mechanisms
that provide a payback for investors and
these can include a variety of tools
such as direct lending and co-lending
on-bill financing credit enhancements
including loan loss reserves and loan
guarantees and pace
state green banks finally are also
playing a critical role in bringing
clean energy investments to scale small
disaggregated projects are notoriously
hard to finance especially for uh energy
efficiency it is just too expensive for
institutional investors to underwrite
such small loans so green banks
warehouse smaller loans and securitize
or sell the loans once the warehouse is
adequately large
next slide please
it goes without saying that establishing
a state green bank is no small feat and
requires going through a number of
steps but generally you may think of you
know
three
stages to establishing a
state green bank
in the first stage a coalition of
stakeholders which can include clean
energy organizations cleantech trade
association environmental groups and
state agencies
these stakeholders establish a base of
support for a green bank and this
support is really critical to passing
legislation
or achieving the required regulatory
change to legally create a green bank
in the
second stage the green bank organization
or entity is established and this can
include different things like hiring
staff building capabilities identifying
goals assessing markets and developing
products
and in the final stage the green bank
actually begins acquiring customers
lending in partnership with private
investors and recycling funds in order
to
recapitalize uh the bank
and one important question uh that
needs to be uh addressed is regarding
the uh
structure
of the uh the green bank
and um although a green bank may take a
variety of forms the generally three uh
structures to consider
uh first as was done in connecticut uh
the bring the green bank uh can be a
standalone as a quasi-independent entity
and this kind of model allows for the
most uh flexibility and uh autonomy
uh another option is for green bank to
be housed within an existing
state agency
the new york green bank
operates
according to that model
lastly a green bank may be incorporated
into an infrastructure bank where it
would likely be established as a
separate uh subsidiary
and um regarding the
the sources of funding so it can receive
its initial funding from several public
sources
in both connecticut and new york
existing state funds system benefit
charges were repurposed and regional
greenhouse gas initiative funds they
also provide also provided uh initial
capital for the green bank
uh alternately uh as was done in hawaii
uh the state can issue bonds to private
investors
then state green banks can also receive
money from cap and trade option revenues
and private foundations
this will obviously all depend on the
state and
legal structure established when the
green bank is
created
next slide
um the state green bank movement uh is
really gaining uh momentum um
connecticut created the first green bank
in 2011 and in the three years since
then
the green bank there has facilitated uh
350 million dollars in clean energy
investments that's the same amount that
the prior making entity did in 11 years
the new york has created its own one
billion dollar green bank and that was
in 2013 and it has already announced 800
million dollars of clean energy
investments 600 of which is from private
investors alone
then hawaii california and new jersey
have created similar clean energy
finance initiatives and the common thing
across all these uh you know state green
banks is that they intend to leverage
private dollars to increase investment
in clean reliable energy then there are
other states like minnesota vermont
maryland rhode island
uh and possibly others which are also
exploring
their own
green bank initiatives
i guess to sum up i would say that
without green banks
the private sector may eventually find
ways to provide low cost financing for
deploying uh clean technologies but this
might be sometimes far into the future
and i'm not sure we can afford to wait
for that
so i'll stop here and
happy to take questions later
excellent uh well thanks devashree i'm
uh casey bell i'm the senior economist
uh with the american council for an
energy efficient economy and i lead our
finance policy work um but i'm happy to
talk to you today
uh about the current landscape for
energy efficiency finance policy
and uh when we're talking about energy
efficiency we aren't necessarily talking
about generation uh we're talking about
measures and technologies that save
energy at the point of delivery
next slide
so for those of you unfamiliar with the
american council for an energy efficient
economy ac triple e we are
about to have our 35 year anniversary
this slides a little out of date
and we are a non-profit that
supports its advocacy work for energy
efficiency through our externally
reviewed research
we are possibly best known for our state
energy efficiency scorecard which ranks
the states by their energy efficiency
policy and i would encourage you if you
take a look at where your state is if
you'd like to see that number go up uh
to reach out to me after the
presentation and we can connect you with
our state policy staff
the finance policy program focuses on
best practice policies and market
mechanisms for driving energy efficiency
investment
slide
we also host an annual energy efficiency
finance forum every year as i plan this
event which sees about 300 attendees
i like to think in themes and the theme
this year
around energy efficiency finance and
energy efficiency investment really is a
critical moment
like
while we're seeing an unprecedented
amount of capital be deployed into the
marketplace we're also seeing shifts in
policy
that are both uh helping us to deliver
that more effectively
as well as to drive demand for energy
efficiency and we want to talk a little
bit about policies at the federal state
and local level uh that support
uh demand for energy efficiency finance
so you see on this slide that we have um
oh that's all right
uh
we are working with a market that has a
279 billion dollar investment potential
that's a number that was estimated in
2011 by the rockefeller foundation and
deutsche bank and that the industry is
moving along through parallel tracks
on the one hand we're trying to put
together infrastructure to drive capital
to the market uh both by attracting
investors as well as trying to figure
out how to build energy efficiency loan
products into asset-backed securities to
sell the secondary markets we're
developing mechanisms for effective
delivery uh that you know can
potentially be structured to serve
harder to reach markets
and at the same time we're also
investing in solutions that drive demand
both on the policy side and on in terms
of intelligent efficiency uh or uh
information technologies that can give
you more information about building
energy use which may serve down the road
to drive additional demand for energy
efficiency investment next slide please
very briefly uh
this is a slide that sort of captures uh
that first theme on driving capital into
the market and it shows a number of the
players in this space that are providing
capital for different types of projects
and financing efficiency through
different mechanisms
across different sides and different
sectors of the market
next side
please
these next two slides uh just highlight
uh some promising mechanisms on bill
financing um which has been
adopted in the following states as well
as next slide uh pace programs or
property assess clean energy which
allows customers to uh repay their
efficiency obligations through a
property tax assessment and these are
the states that have adopted policies
and implemented programs
next slide
and dentistry talked about the green
bank movement uh so i won't spend too
much time on this but these are some of
the states that are either considering
um or have uh adopted a a or i've
started to uh implementing a green bank
next slide
and you can just skip to the next one
uh moving back to the theme of a
critical moment uh driving demand and
the theme of this webinar i'm just going
to talk a little bit now about how
policy is evolving to support financing
at the federal state and local level
you see now that 24 states have
mandatory energy-saving schools or
energy efficiency resource standards
these are a huge demand driver for
energy efficiency investment although we
do see these threatened in some states
40 plus states have national model
building codes eight percent of national
electric generating capacity is from
combined heat and power
it's estimated that 1.1 trillion dollars
will be saved from existing appliance
standards and equipment efficiencies
through 2035.
next slide
for once i'm thrilled to announce some
good news out of washington
so just last week the president signed
into law the energy efficiency
improvement act of 2015.
this is a collection of three useful but
relatively modest provisions on
residential water heaters and commercial
buildings but it really is um we see it
as a positive step forward and in a
remarkable show of coordination and
convergence uh both houses of congress
have scheduled hearings next week um on
energy efficiency the house has not
released any details on its hearing yet
uh but uh we know that the senate energy
committee hearing will cover 22 bills
that have been introduced this year
and our executive director has been
invited to to testify at that hearing um
if you'd like some more information at
some of the policies that are going to
be discussed please follow up with me
afterwards
but a lot of the policies that are
listed on this slide are on the table
next slide please
perhaps our best hope for driving demand
for energy efficiency investments is
rule 111d
so 111d
the epa is requiring states to develop
implement implementation plans for
emissions reductions using its authority
under the clean air act next slide
a report by ac triple e demonstrates
that for many states savings goals can
be met mostly or entirely through energy
efficiency we are in the process of
preparing technical assistance on how
financing might be included as part of a
compliance strategy
now the final rule was expected in june
but may slip to july or possibly even
later i'm hearing uh we are also
expecting court cases to challenge the
rule
that said uh we don't expect these
challenges to slow the 12-month clock
between the final rule and the due date
for implementation plans
so it
is really probably a best practice for
states not to delay their planning
because if they
don't begin to put together their
compliance plans they risk getting stuck
with a federally mandated plan
next slide please
and these are four policies that we
highlight within the report
that can help
states within their implementation plan
to to reduce emissions
and we see
you know the annual energy savings goals
um investment in combined heat and power
uh being real opportunities uh for
financiers that want to get involved
within the
the energy efficiency space uh building
energy codes may certainly go a long way
to drive demand for projects as well
next slide
in addition there's lots of policies to
drive demand at the state and local
level so we just highlight a few of
these here
the energy efficiency resource standards
again
have a very very high potential
to to drive demand
and then we also see
policies such as loan loss reserves
as being credit enhancements that may
help
mitigate
risks from an investor perspective in
engaging in
funding for energy efficiency
we see benchmarking and disclosure
policies and policies that help us
better understand
building energy uses as potential demand
drivers
excide please
and you can just get to the next one too
a key to unlocking demand from our
perspective isn't just providing loans
it's making sure the energy efficiency
is property
excuse me properly valued by owner
some
data initiatives
that are designed to again give us
better information around building
energy used to potentially drive demands
next slide
so i'm just going to leave you with some
final food for thought when it comes to
delivering financing effectively we in
the energy efficiency community are now
facing two of these open-ended questions
um as we talk about um you know how best
to deploy financing solutions
uh
we see that many offerings are
capitalized or subsidized by repair
dollars uh so the first question that we
have here um is what is the best way to
deploy public dollars to maximize energy
savings um and then the second question
which we see is very important at ace is
since we're using public dollars for
deploying financing solutions how do we
ensure equitable access to the multiple
benefits of energy efficiency
and with that teaser final slide here
if you're interested in the policies and
the issues that i've highlighted here i
strongly encourage you um to attend our
annual energy efficiency finance forum
which will be june 1st through 2nd in
san francisco where uh we will be
exploring these issues in much greater
depth
and i should also mention that
if you have a project that is currently
in need of capital uh this is the final
week to apply for our pbsa deal room we
are working with cdfa best present next
um to
match projects that
are relevant within the space to capital
we have a lot of financiers that attend
the conference we have a very very uh
brief uh application that's attached to
this slide and i would encourage you if
you have any questions or think that you
might have a project
that is eligible to to reach out to me
after the webinar
so thank you very much and i will turn
it over to jason
great thank you casey and definitely
thank you for mentioning the deal room
we're really excited to be working with
you guys on that i'm looking forward to
going out there and the projects we've
been talking with so far seem really
interesting so looking forward to
getting actually be in the room with
them and find some investors
so thank you
all right so
again thank you all for being on the
call today i think this is a really
interesting topic and i enjoyed getting
to hear my fellow panelists talking
about their perspective on policy energy
policy is definitely an area that i
found to be particularly engaging one of
the things that has always struck me is
really interesting about it
from my perspective that cdfa is how
isolated it can be from the rest of
economic development
so for those of you who don't know i'm
just using cdfa in 30 seconds we're
national trade association we have more
than 400 member organizations throughout
the country most of them are public
sector the groups that do economic
development finance that finance fees is
particularly our niche so the groups
that do bonds tax increments loan
programs and tax credit investment
programs
and again we're all throughout the
country so we work with both state and
local level and on the private side we
also work with banks law firms and
project consultants and really focus on
how you finance economic development and
how you finance anything that might be
counted as economic development so we
have programming best practices and
research and technical assistance that
supports infrastructure finance small
business finance brownfield finance and
then energy as well and one thing that
we noticed when people started to come
to us more and our members started to
talk to us more about clean energy and
how to finance renewables how to finance
energy efficiency
we started to understand just how
separate so many communities throughout
the country keep their energy offices
and particularly the renewable energy
offices
from their economic development offices
and on the service there are some
reasons why that makes sense but what's
interesting is that a lot of times
infrastructure gets financed in the same
way you know regardless of what type of
infrastructure it is and to us energy
you know definitely is a piece of
infrastructure it's it's part of you
know electricity and so it seems pretty
clearly the infrastructure we didn't
really see that as being much of a
question mark but then because of that
being treated separately
by the state agencies what we saw is
that there are many places that really
only focus on energy specific programs
so if i'm going to finance energy
whether that means renewables or if that
means
efficiency then i need a you know
branded quotation marks however you want
to look at a capital letters energy
program and what we tried to do once we
started to identify that was
help communities think through their
existing economic development finance
tools and how those can be put to use
either directly or with some
modifications and then be able to
finance energy improvements and do some
of the work that you know i think we all
want to do to try to have more efficient
energy use to try to have better sources
of energy generation
and so our focus in the energy space at
cfa has really been on integrating
economic development and energy programs
and policies you know in addition that
energy's infrastructure piece the other
reason that we look at it is finances
finance if you have a project that has
you know a good source of repayment or
you have a borrower who is creditworthy
then at the end of the day
we can convince the market to want to
take that project's debt on you know
regardless of what the financing itself
actually is and sometimes it does take
some convincing particularly you know we
saw with solar
more so up to the last couple of years
that banks fund writers were concerned
about the technological risk that went
along with the normal borrower risk but
i think those challenges are starting to
be put to rest at least um
we're in a better position than we were
a few years ago and so once again you
get to that point where a deal is a deal
and so let's look at how we can start to
finance some of the energy programs with
tools that we have right now
so our focus on that policy and the
focus that i want to take today because
again we do cover a wide range of
policies at cdfa but what i wanted to
focus on today is federal policy
that leaves decision-making about
projects and sometimes even about
spending priorities at the local level
because that sort of federal to
state or local relationship i think is
really critical
in part because the federal government
obviously has a lot more financial
assets than many state and local
governments do but then also because
it's a way to try to address the
equality or at least the equity of
having these programs in place if you
just leave everything on the energy
space up to the states what we saw from
that great map
from all the great maps that casey had
what ends up happening there are certain
states that care a lot more about this
or are able to put together the
political will to make a difference and
then other states don't whereas if you
have a policy that's at the federal
level but still leaves that decision
making local we found that when it's
time to put their the money where the
mouth is a lot of states regardless how
red they are still willing to work with
some of these programs and make
improvements in their state so it's um
so that's where we want to focus today
on that federal policy at the local
level so one of the main tools that we
work with at cdfa and that i want to
talk about now
is tax exempt bonds and how they can
play in the energy space
so a tax bond
anytime you're dealing with a bond
you're really just talking about a debt
instrument so it's a loan it's just a
massive loan that's being sold to
investors instead of to the bank
at least in most cases keeping things
high level here so what is a nice
benefit about tax exam funds these
conclude municipal bonds that are issued
by a city or state and backed by the
city or state and they can also cover
private activity bonds but what's nice
about those bonds in regards to the
forum is that they're the interest is
exempt from federal income tax and
typically state and local as well
and so as a result the investor isn't
paying taxes on the money they're making
from holding the bond and so they don't
need the interest rate to be as high in
that bond as they would if it was
taxable because at the end of the day
if they're going to pay a couple
percentage points worth of interest and
they're willing to just accept the lower
interest rate in the first place and i
have to pay tax on it it works out to be
the same or better for the investor and
what that means for projects what means
on the energy side is that if you can
use taxes and bonds to pay for your
energy project then you can have a
cheaper project or a bigger project
depending on how you look at it
so that taxes and bonds the nutshell
when it comes to private activity bonds
these are taxes and bonds that are used
for private development and there are
three main kinds that can be
particularly useful for energy
development
the first that i have in this list here
is industrial development bonds these
are bonds that go to small to mid-sized
manufacturers they're capped at 10
million dollars so that's the biggest
bond you can have for these projects
and they need to be to a relatively
smaller again or mid-size manufacturer
because there are limitations on how
much
that company can have spent on
facilities or lane acquisition in a
certain window but without getting to
the nuts and bolts smaller size
manufacturers 10 million dollars in
bonds and they can be tax exempt done
and what you can do with this and the
energy space is you can put solar panels
or you can put wind
in some cases you can make efficient
upgrades especially if they're just
moving into a new building and as long
as these upgrades are happening with
the part of the manufacturer that
actually does manufacturing so not just
the warehousing not just the
the you know r d department or something
but actually the manufacturing piece
then you can use these bonds and you can
do improvements on manufacturers and
manufacturing of course is a huge huge
sector when it comes to the uses of
energy so doing what we can to improve
the energy use here can be really key
51c3 bonds are also eligible for energy
they can do both efficiency and they can
finance renewables again so if there's a
51c3 operator the world wildlife fund
had a really big bond that they did it
helped finance their
led i think it's i think they were
platinum on their dc office they came
over certain but they had 5123 bonds
there jews have used these before so
five one security operators can get
access to taxes and funds
and then exempt facilities bonds and
these ones actually want to go into a
little bit more exempt facilities bonds
finance public private infrastructure so
if you think about many of your major
energy users once you get past
manufacturing a lot of times you're
looking at
infrastructure things like
you know water treatment plants
waste plants
so those are types of
infrastructures you can finance with
exam facilities bonds and you can
then use these bonds to get low cost
capital to make improvements um we've
seen several communities throughout the
country take a look at putting solar
panels on their wastewater treatment
plants or doing other types of
processing that can really reduce their
energy costs and this is the type of
bond that even if you have a private
operator it can be applicable
exempt facilities bonds can also finance
combined heat power in biomass as long
as it's a private operator they can do
that regardless of the facility type so
if you have a manufacturer maybe too big
to be able to use an industrial
development bond but they want to do
biomass you can use an exam facilities
bond and then finance it that way so a
lot of good options now
you see on this list here that's
absolutely bonds can finance combine
heat power and biomass anywhere but what
they can't finance is other renewables
and they can't really be used for
efficiency improvement so one policy
point the cdfa has been working with a
few different members of congress in the
senate on over the last few years and is
i'm working on again now is to try to
have renewables added into the exam
facilities definition you can also
finance solar and wind um definitely
makes sense with the other categories
that are currently financed with the
exact facilities language then you could
finance a lot more renewable
installations throughout the country for
a lot of different types of operators
and they'd be able to do it more
affordably and therefore be more likely
to do it
so
in some ways related to bonds but apart
from bonds i also want to talk for a
moment here about credit enhancement so
one issue that does come up with any
type of project when you're trying to
look at financing it and going through a
debt tool is trying to figure out where
that repayment source is going to come
from
and
a lot of times particularly with the
regulations where they are bank doesn't
just want to see that you have a
repayment source but they also want to
know that they have great collateral
great coverage a really strong loan to
value so there are thresholds that they
have to get to before a bank is going to
be willing to finance any type of
project
sometimes that can be tough for an
energy project if you're trying to talk
a business into making an improvement or
making some sort of
renewable installation on their property
well they might be able to pay for it
with the lower energy costs and so
they're willing to go to it go through
with the project there but if they don't
also want to commit um you know
additional assets they have is
collateral then they could end up in a
situation where they're a little bit
short on the credit side
so there are a number of instances where
this comes in play manufacturers have to
challenge small businesses have a
similar type of challenge and so energy
isn't going alone and what we've seen on
the manufacturing and energy and small
business side is that there are a great
deal of programs that are able to
provide credit enhancement from public
monies but the bank can accept the bank
to make the regulators happy because
they're using credit enhancement it
doesn't have to be tied to the borrower
as long as the bank's protected and so
they're able to then lend to these
projects so the federal state small
business credit initiative is a really
innovative program style where treasury
was allocated money by congress treasury
approved small business credit programs
to the states but the state's running
their own programs there are over 150
programs that are being operated from
state small business credit initiative
funding and so that's allowed a great
deal of flexibility not to paint just a
rosy picture it's definitely had the
challenges as well as some states pick
programs that weren't designed optimally
but we've been able to develop quite a
few best practices
and on the whole states were able to
design programs with federal funding
that fit their specific local needs and
so it's been a really really powerful
program for small business lending
so cfa has two policies id policy ideas
in this area one is a federal state
clean energy finance initiative for um
just the lack of a better name i suppose
but taking that same ssbci model but
applying it to clean energy the federal
government can provide funds that the
states could use to provide credit
enhancement and provide
capital access for energy projects
based on the challenges in their
specific states then you'd be able to
see a lot more of this type of
investment throughout the country again
regardless of what the political
appetite for each particular state might
be also in um very much to demonstrate's
point that she had early on states
should also be looking to invest in
energy credit enhancement it doesn't fit
the broad perspective that we prefer to
say at cdfa but states
instead of just looking at financing
how do we grant money how do we loan to
a project and take all of that project
risk on to ourselves so they should also
be looking at how we can make they can
make investments into programs that just
support that do a better job of
enhancing
a loan so that they're leveraging a lot
more private dollars so
that's the perspective i want to present
today and a handful of policy proposals
that we're really focused on here at
cdfa and i am very much looking forward
to having more of a policy conversation
with questions that you can all submit
to us and then
questions that michael at yale has for
the panel thank you
great thanks jason thanks all the uh
thanks to the other speakers as well um
so i'm gonna throw a few questions uh to
you guys we'll start sort of broad and
then we can we can get a little bit more
specific as more audience questions come
in
um
first question was what do all of you
see as the role of the state government
versus sorry as of the federal
government versus state governments
versus local governments
in shaping clean energy finance from a
policy point of view
this is jason i'd be happy to jump in
first on this one so you know as i said
the perspective that we're taking at
least for today is really looking at
trying to have capital come from the
federal government
again mostly focused on that is kind of
an equity point but really the states
and the locals need to be the drivers on
this both because
one there's a lot that they can do if
you're a state or local government and
you want to do these types of programs
there are a lot of different ways you
can capitalize loan programs that you
can be creative about looking for
funding sources um you know deborah she
mentioned the systems benefits charges
before we actually know of a city that
is looking at doing a kind of pool
purchasing and then taking part of the
savings that the ratepayers will
experience and using that to kind of
create their own systems benefits charge
where they're going to put half of the
savings into an account so you get
really creative at the state local level
if you want to but we do like to see the
federal government play a role in at
least
supporting programs as they can so that
there's equal access across the country
yeah and uh i'll just add uh that um
even uh at brooklyn even though we feel
that you know um the federal government
there has been a huge fullback
we do emphasize that both state
government and the federal government
needs to
work in
you know partnership and just to give
the perspective from the green bank side
uh state green banks can work with or
without uh federal programs uh to
support clean energy but i think they
are most effectively
more effective when they build upon what
is offered uh by the federal government
uh for instance uh many of the potential
private investors in clean energy
projects are encouraged by uh tax
credits or subsidies which are provided
at the federal level and if these
incentives are eliminated it greatly
reduces the private investor appetite
for clean energy investment that
straight that state green banks aim to
leverage uh so definitely uh you know
the federal government you know has a
huge uh role to play as well it had a
long history of financing uh large
critical infrastructure that offers
broader public benefits to citizens and
that's a role that we would like to you
know continue to see
and um i would just uh follow up by
saying uh
while the state and local governments
probably have the greatest potential for
you know developing the solutions and
and deploying them um that the federal
government uh
can play a really important role um in
setting standards uh both um or you know
legislatively um and you know
administratively through through setting
standards for emissions and building
codes um but also um you know through
some of its administrative authority and
helping us to answer some of these um
valuation questions
that sort of
present a bit of a market failure within
the government within the market for
energy efficiency finance
great
okay so on the topic of uh state level
action um
you know i've seen a lot of um
movement uh especially for the green
bank model in uh you know in the
northeast and in some of the uh the more
sort of blue states uh and not much
progress in the red states so my
question is
do you see the green bank model catching
on in red states how do you see that
happening
and particularly how do you sell that
model to
legislators or to the general public who
isn't necessarily um as concerned about
climate change as uh you know as other
parts of the country
i think we see a lot of potential in uh
sort of the movement towards resiliency
investment so um you know while the
first movers on the green bank front
have been new york and connecticut
as well as california and hawaii
we also see that new jersey
which one wouldn't necessarily classify
as a red state but one certainly that is
led by a republican governor right now
um
making a move toward investing in
resiliency which can often include clean
energy and energy efficiency um in fact
that's a critical component of
resiliency investment
so um you know new jersey's in an
interesting position because it's
responding in some ways to hurricane
sandy but um i think we see a lot of red
states in areas that uh could benefit
from a more stable uh grid
so i think that that's that's one
opportunity of the other comments that i
would make um is that uh
you know as we establish these green
banks we should also be looking to uh
sort of the existing programs within the
state that have been delivering
energy efficiency finance uh some for
for many years now uh through you know
other programs um and how do you know
sort of leverage effective lessons
learned from those programs
um as we sort of build them into these
uh sort of centralized models
yeah and uh i'll just jump in um and add
here that uh in dealing with uh many uh
states especially through uh hosting the
green bank academy uh we heard this
comment uh you know that i don't believe
in climate change or i suppose you know
the continued use of fossil fuel in my
energy market so why should i um support
a green bank
so i guess you know
the quick answer there would be that you
know one does not have to be worried
about you know carbon emissions to
recognize the value of energy efficiency
um you know by reducing wasted energy
through retrofits and better
construction and consuming energy more
widely through let's say you know smart
grid technologies total energy
consumption can be reduced
um so you know green banks you know help
consumers save money on energy
strengthen our national security and
generate other economic benefits
independent of any discussion on uh
climate change
and um generally we have seen that green
bank can be and have been supported by
members of both parties simply because
you know they help to create cheaper
cleaner and more reliable energy you
know things
which
both red and blue safe should like
so i really like this question and
honestly it's exactly why cfa is not
really a proponent of green banks we
definitely like the concept of them but
um politically does get to be a hard
sell so i wouldn't necessarily look for
any of
your very conservative states or
states regardless of their political
affiliation that have big coal
interests in them to be putting a green
bank in place because politically that's
not going to happen so instead what you
want to focus on with those states is on
an infrastructure bank or on how they
can
well basically put an infrastructure
bank or how they can be more aggressive
about using their existing tools to
finance energy and so you know you think
of a state like
um
you know new mexico that's a state that
really
it's kind of on the cusp i guess in
terms of where exactly they fall
politically and they're not very
aggressive on the energy side at least
um that i've seen but they do have an
infrastructure bank that they put in
place even more so north dakota
definitely a state that's not you know
real big on
democratic policies but they've got an
infrastructure bank in place that's
great so if that bank is willing to go
and look at energy projects as well
then they can still be able to finance
them
really effectively we've heard a lot
from about kentucky not wanting to take
on green because they have too much coal
interest and they're not going to do
green but they're putting pace in place
so a lot of it is just going to be about
how you actually
talk to the politicians so instead of
maybe focusing on the greens instead of
focusing on renewables focus on
infrastructure and that infrastructure
includes energy and that if you do
energy efficiency or if you allow
manufacturers or businesses to choose
for themselves to take a renewable path
and just provide them a cheaper way to
finance it then
you're going to save those manufacturers
money and get more jobs so again when we
talk about this issue we like to focus
on affordable capital on um
infrastructure and on jobs and i think
that's the way you go with those states
and then they might not create a you
know cooperating bank but you can get
the powers and tools that a green bank
would have
right and a final note just to piggyback
on that from a policy perspective uh
while we see a lot of promise um in sort
of the the green bank model uh we do see
a need for them to demonstrate some
proof of concept uh before you know in
terms of uh being sort of a high value
in terms of energy savings uh before we
pour all of our public resources that
have been dedicated to setting up uh
mechanisms for delivering uh energy
efficiency to um
um to customers
we would like to we'd like to see some
proof of concept before advocating that
all those dollars be poured into the
degree before advocating for a
widespread adoption of the green bank
model
all right um so the next question comes
from the audience from dan
uh who's asking about um
regional or state level carbon taxes or
cap and trade schemes i was wondering
what role these could play in supporting
or funding some of these policies
assuming that federal action you know
federal carbon tax or a federal traffic
cap and trade scheme is probably pretty
unlikely at this stage
well i can talk a little bit about the
um you know the clean power plan um and
uh you know sort of the the state the
federal media that states uh meet
certain levels of emissions reductions
um you know again while again widespread
cap and trade policy is not very likely
um you know this is this is sort of a
one of those one of the ways in which
the federal government is setting
standards um we are in the process we
think that establishing financing
programs
could be an effective uh compliance
mechanism if in fact um
we can design them in such a way to
encourage uptake um
but uh the challenge uh
from for
helping them to meet that standard is um
finding the most appropriate way to
measure and evaluate the effectiveness
of these programs but we are in the
process of developing technical
assistance
around
how that could be accomplished
so the other thing that i'll add on to
that is that i believe that california's
new policy
that they're putting in place is going
to actually provide a source of capital
that they're going to be able to put
back into programs they have
environmental benefits i'm not sure how
much that is going to go to
energy programs or exactly what type
people are also looking at it for
environmental cleanup and some other
issues as well but if you have a policy
that is going to be raising money from
people who are from businesses that are
in compliance then that's the potential
source of fund capitalization
great okay the next question um also
comes from a different daniel
and he's asking about any experiences or
any knowledge out there amongst the
panelists for our financing models
really looking at low-income residents
around community solar projects or
community energy efficiency projects
and how policy instruments might be used
to help grow that portion of the market
i can jump in
and say that
green banks uh can support low-cost uh
income specific clean energy programs um
in a number of ways uh including by
offering low-cost uh low funds or loan
guarantees to cdfi's uh other community
organizations and non-profits
they can also establish loan loss
reserves that can reduce the credit
requirements uh necessary for consumers
to access clean energy programs i know
that the connecticut greenback is
working to reduce the barriers faced by
home owners to obtain rooftop solar
through the solarized connecticut
program
the program has reduced its minimum
credit score requirements for solar
diesels to 640
though this credit barrier is still too
high for many uh low-income families
yeah that's that's definitely good the
connecticut model is a good one to look
at i actually would really encourage
daniel to check out i believe it was the
last webinar we did michael correct me
if i'm wrong but we had um
gosh with chris from denver housing
authority talking about what they do to
finance
solar and energy efficiency on low
income housing and one of the big tools
that they use is hud has a kind of
guarantee of a power purchase agreement
program
that low income residential projects can
put into place so i definitely would
encourage you to look back at that
some other things that we've seen it's
possible potentially to use special
assessment
type of programs or tax lingering
finance to do solar projects you'd have
to have a pretty solid district and have
a developer really committed to it but
that'd be something else you could
another way you could finance it in
addition to
other programs that connecticut put in
place you might want to look at you yeah
and i would just add uh recently
last year uh center for american
progress uh released a paper on state
policies to increase uh low-income
communities access to solar power so
that may be uh and that has you know
some good examples so that may be
something that you may want to look at
as well but that just focuses on photos
great thanks for that and um yeah jason
that's that's right we did
address a bit of that in the last
webinar
and those sites are available for
download at the cba website so if you um
yeah if you browse around there you'll
see the webinar 2 from this series
covers a lot of those issues
okay so next we've actually had a couple
more questions about green banks um
i'm going to try to combine them into
one long convoluted question but uh to
what extent uh and this comes from steve
and vanessa to what extent do green
banks seek to provide good value to
customers as opposed to investors in
contrast to many solar leasing options
out there that aren't really providing
great value to customers these days
and also what sort of default rates um
are green banks experiencing right now
and how does that really compare to uh
private cost of capital that um you know
that the risks that are placing private
investors
um well i'll start with the second uh
question first the default rate i know
it is uh you know pretty low though i
don't have the exact uh statistics uh
now but i think it's a lot i heard it
was less than one percent uh but don't
quote me on that um
and
i think green banks um definitely offer
um you know a great value to consumers
you know also investors i mean they are
increasing the value of you know
taxpayer dollars through leveraging uh
private capital they're catalyzing
market transformation
and generating a host of
other public goods um
and
i mean they have just you know reduced
the upfront cost for accessing uh clean
energy uh programs in in the states that
you know that they have taken rules
especially connecticut and we've seen
that uh
somewhat uh in uh new york as well
yeah i also do not have numbers specific
to green banks looking more broadly
across the types of programs that green
banks put into place
the municipal markets the last five
years are well below this percentage
point in terms of default around point
zero three i think you might come up
closer to a percentage if you're looking
only at private activity bonds but
default rate there is again very very
low
and those tools are backing up the
capital source for a lot of these sub
loans and so if um
you know those tools are doing really
well in terms of defaults and you're
going to see a pretty low rate as well
on the loans that are coming out of the
green banks most of the time in terms of
the general economic development loan
fund it's pretty common it seems like
most of the members so we know what
their default rates are are under five
percent usually and those are funds that
are specifically designed to be a little
bit
more risk-taking because they're you
know stepping in where banks won't so
five percent of course is still pretty
good and many of them are more around
two percent or even lower um
kind of also depends on exactly how
you're finding defaults they define
default typically a little bit more
broadly than of course
uh more literally i guess than a banquet
as well but still pretty low rates there
so i think you're looking at good
success you don't have a lot of history
sometimes i mean i was talking to a bank
investor who's interested investing in
loan funds and they want eight years of
track record and you don't have a lot of
funds out there that have those types of
numbers available yet
mike did we get that michael did we get
the whole question i forgot the first
part so the first part was really about
you know to what extent do green banks
seek to provide good value to customers
as opposed to investors and i think you
know in bringing down the cost of
capital and uh
you know that kind of um
it all ties together i guess
yeah absolutely i think that's where
they do provide the benefit is that they
can do it at a lower cost um the number
that every it seems like every energy
program that i look at is really focused
on is you know how many years until
this is paying for itself um you know
what's your what's your payback going to
be and that number keeps coming down and
having a financing tool that lowers your
interest rate is just going to you know
get you that payback point even sooner
so i would say that's the value the
customers get
great so unfortunately that that takes
us to the end of the webinar we're out
of time um
but uh i'd like to thank uh davashree
casey and jason for making this really
fantastic webinar i'd like to thank
everyone for listening in and
contributing to
far too many questions we had time to
put to everyone
and i'd like to remind everyone that
today's talk will be made available
online through the yale center for
business and environment website as are
the other
presentations in this series
so
with that i would like to say please
keep an eye out for the next series of
webinars when we return in the fall
and so long from new haven connecticut
thank you
thank you
thank you